what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the hulk right with uh
with hulk part three and and i don't
know why i keep getting the wires
crossed with like donnie cates and al
ewing like in the venom video we were
like it's donnie case's venom but it's
actually al ewing's venom it's probably
because the two of them directly
switched stories which always throws me
off donnie case was writing venom
alleyways writing hulk then they
switched and donnie case is writing hulk
and al ewing's writing venom and it just
it takes me for a loop sometimes so i
may make that mistake a couple more
times hopefully not i'll try to make
sure i don't but the whole idea behind
the incredible hulk because donnie cates
is writing it right now uh is that
basically bruce banner is piloting the
incredible hulk
now if you want to get caught up make
sure you guys check out the playlist
down in the description which will not
only have this incredible hulk story all
the way at the bottom but we'll also
have a whole bunch of other incredible
hulk stuff to go along with it including
the immortal hulk but the whole thing
behind this is that banner is basically
in an alternate reality and the crazy
thing is that this alternate reality
he's in is one that's actually occupied
by a another version of bruce banner now
before we get into that there is
something really important here and this
is one of those instances where dottie
cates teases a thing and then kind of
gives us this slow introduction it's
usually what he always does you could
set your watch to it right so he'll give
us like the first two issues which will
set the stage and then we'll get issue
number three which is something's coming
and then we'll get issue number four
which may or may not focus on that and
then with five and six we'll basically
come to the fruition of what's going on
with the thing he discussed assuming
he's going to keep it confined to those
six issues and not really like build it
up as something that'll show up in like
you know 12 or 24 issues later on down
the line but the thing about this and
really the big question that we'd all
had is that at the end of al ewing's run
on the immortal hulk that banner and
hulk had basically kind of found a way
to work in unison right there was
harmony there as there usually always is
when it comes to the ending of a hulk
story what we didn't know is what had
happened between the time of the ending
of immortal hulk and the events in el
paso when things had basically popped
off and the incredible hulk had somehow
lost his mind and started tearing
everything up that what had basically
happened is things had kind of gone back
to the status quo that basically
whenever the incredible hulk essentially
came on that where he and banner would
kind of work in unison and both would
basically know what the other one was
doing that banner was basically shut out
and so things started going nuts and he
didn't fully understand what was
happening the other part of this is that
when the when the questions asked what
happened like like you know his belief
being that like the incredible hulk had
basically just taken over shut banner's
mind out and then went on a war path in
el paso killed a whole bunch of people
and then basically you know kind of
reverted back into banner then instead
there's something else going on here
that seemingly there's another kind of
hulk presence that's there almost
demonic in nature and then just
basically refers to banner as being weak
and then kills banner right off the bat
now of course this is him seemingly
having like a dream experience it's not
actually him experiencing that so we
don't know exactly how this unfolded if
it was a vision that took place in el
paso if it's something that he's just
imagining right some sort of way for him
to kind of cope with the the things that
like the incredible hulk actually did in
el paso we don't necessarily know all we
know is that he basically wakes up in
this alternate reality and is met with
this version of bruce spanner now the
crazy thing about this is that this
alternate reality version of banner as
he says he describes him as being
magnificent and says i have never met an
abomination with such agency before and
so seemingly in this alternate reality
there appears to be more than one hulk
and those various versions that are out
there don't really have the same kind of
intelligence that bruce banner does now
the funny thing about this is that this
is kind of the exception to the rule
whether it's because of the fact that
bruce banner is basically controlling
the incredible hulk so like piloting the
hulk and using the hulk's anger as a
means to essentially control his body to
increase his strength or decrease his
strength as needed or previous
iterations where you had like professor
hulk or even like world breaker hulk or
something like that that regardless of
the situation seemingly this alternate
reality version of banner has never
encountered that and so when the the
main marvel universe banner introduced
himself as i am basically bruce banner
and i'm controlling the incredible hulk
i'm piloting him basically like my mind
is controlling the body then this
alternate reality version of banner is
like okay that's interesting i'm curious
about this and so of course with the
incredible hulk persona it really is his
mind kind of facing off against all
these different threats that banner
shuts the threats down which of course
lead to the incredible hulk persona
basically calming down right remember
that's how this whole thing works the
incredible hulk is basically the engine
that you have the physical incredible
hulk's body but you have the mind of
bruce banner that's controlling the
incredible hulk's body and that what you
have is the incredible hulk mind
basically the savage hulk's mind being
forced to fight enemy after enemy after
enemy increasing his rage which allows
the incredible hulk to stay strong so
banner can basically control the hulk's
strength right remember that's kind of
the thing that's going on here it's
interesting and it's kind of
meta-textual but in the midst of all
this kind of happening the incredible
whole persona meets with what looks like
this kind of dark demonic devil hulk
version the crazy thing is that he seems
to have seen him before it's one of
those things where he's like you right
like who are you and then when this
version takes off the whole kind of
chases after him right and he's like
please come back so it's an interesting
concept because it looks as though the
incredible hulk wants this kind of devil
version of himself or this being or
whatever it is this happens to be again
we don't fully know what's going on here
the important thing that to really
discuss here is basically maine marvel
universe banner talking to alternate
banner and what we get is this bit of an
origin story in that this alternate
reality universe version of bruce banner
says that unlike the main marvel
universe where the gamma bomb had gone
off but banner had basically pushed rick
jones out of the way was exposed to the
radiation and then became the incredible
hulk leading to general thunderbolt ross
and all those guys writing the whole
thing off as a failure and basically
saying aftermath of this is basically
just too dangerous that in this
alternate reality it worked right the
gamma bomb went off without a hitch
banner was not caught in the blast he
never became the incredible hulk or
anything along those lines but in his
naivety he believed that this would only
lead to a kind of second atomic age
right that in the aftermath of humanity
discovering atomic energy that yeah i
mean it gave us the cold war and the
fear that the united states and the
soviet union were going to wipe
themselves off the map but it also gave
us microwaves and all kinds of
technology and so the thought of banner
is that sure this could potentially be
used for destructive capabilities but if
for no other reason than
self-preservation humanity would not
necessarily be quick on the trigger in
terms of just detonating all these gamma
bombs across the world in some major
conflict instead they would use gamma
technology as basically a source of
energy to kind of enter into a new age
of human evolution instead the worst
fears of banner come true that there
seemed to have been some kind of just
massive global calamity and what they
ended up doing with the powers that be
as he describes them taking their
weapons and then basically detonating
them across the world everywhere except
for the united states is hit and so what
he says that this whole thing had
basically turned the united states into
the greatest empire in the world
seemingly it was the u.s that struck
first for whatever reason which is not
really explained here what seems to have
happened is that the united states using
gamma bombs targeted the rest of the
world and then detonated all those gamma
bombs in populated areas across the
world leaving only itself as seemingly
the last functioning empire in the world
the last functioning country in the
world and so banner has basically been
trying to continually atone for his
sense and when the question's asked what
are you doing to to atone for your sins
how does all this work he basically says
that the ensuing radiation from these
gamma bomb attacks basically affected
everybody across the world those
individuals who weren't killed in the
explosions were transformed into hulks
but instead of them simply just being
like hulks as you expect them right just
like running around and like an
incredible hulk type person instead
they're all irradiated so some of them
look like look like crabs some of them
are just kind of like welded in place
and it's just like hulk heads or
whatever the case is and sometimes like
you do see a kind of version of the hulk
that basically escapes here's the irony
of all this this is almost exactly how
the events played out in greg pack's
planet hulk event as part of secret wars
right the big difference here is that in
that story everybody in the world were
changed into like tried and true
incredible hulks right incredible hulks
for she-hulk's and like that was
basically it they weren't really mutated
or anything like that it's just
everybody in the world became a hulk
here it's really a an interesting blend
between the events of greg pack's planet
hulk from secret wars which i think was
part of like war zones or something like
that and then uh the events of
incredible hulk the end by peter david
right where basically the world was
destroyed in in nuclear war all the
heroes and all the villains who
basically died out and the incredible
hulk and banner were like the last two
people on earth until the bruce banner
persona had a heart attack and died and
then it was just the incredible hulk and
and i don't really know how a persona
has a heart attack and dies but
regardless it's a very interesting blend
between these two things the other part
of this is that because these hulks kind
of appear out in the world every once in
a while and because this alternate
reality version of banner referred to
them as abominations the question that
the main marvel universe banner is where
are they right when you find these hulks
and you capture them where do they go
what do you do with them and he's like i
found them in the same place that i
found you right out in the void that
basically what this alternate reality
version of banner has been doing is
every time he finds a hulk he basically
throws them out into the void of the
multiverse right just sort of throws
them out there into existence he doesn't
know what happens to them he doesn't
really know where they go and it's not
really his concern and he does this
because he's instructed to and when the
question is asked by banner who
instructs you to do this who tells you
to just throw these incredible hulks
away right to just throw them out right
to maybe study them for a little while
and throw them into the void who tells
you this who is the person that's in
charge here and the response to this
alternate reality version of banner is
my father is it's this father-in-law
president thunderbolt ross with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end i gotta say i'm really
loving the direction this story is going
in i think it's phenomenal but thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace
[Music]